don't see their names on it and the
politicians themselves whilst they're
rich they're not super rich and they can
say we're doing it for the country but
here we have a literal billionaire doing
it you know what I mean and it
highlights what is actually happening
which is that there is a billionaire
class
that is stripping away our government
services and taking our houses and our
assets and putting us into debt you know
what I mean so um having Richardson
there
it's actually good because it it it's
taken the blindfold off and like look
look this is what's happening here you
know I mean the billionaires are taking
your stuff
and yeah normally it's more complicated
that you know they fund think tanks to
you know legitimize ideas that you
shouldn't tax rich people you know what
I mean or they fund economists or they
fund politicians or they own newspapers
you know what I mean but here you
actually have the billionaire coming out
and just doing it himself you know what
I mean so
in a way you know if Rishi goes it will
be a shame because Rishi being there is
the number one advertisement what the
[__] is happening here which is the
billionaires are taking everything and
that's why you can't afford to eat you
know what I mean that's the truth so um